[ Applause ]
>> Jon: HEY, WELCOME TO
"THE DAILY SHOW". MY NAME IS
JON STEWART.
I'M EXCITED WE HAVE GOOD SHOW
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
AND I'M EXCITED ABOUT MY
GUEST, "SELMA" DIRECTOR
AVA DUVERNAY, AND THIS MOVIE IS
PHENOMENAL. YOU HAVE TO SEE IT.
WE'RE VERY EXCITED TO HAVE HER.
BUT FIRST, YOU KNOW -- I THINK
WE'D ALL AGREE 2014 WAS NOT A
GREAT YEAR FOR PEOPLE. BUT
I THINK THE HOPE WAS THAT
2015 WOULD BRING SORT OF
A RESPITE FROM THE KINDS OF
TERRIBLE EVENTS THAT HAVE BECOME
ALL TOO FAMILIAR FOR US.
BUT, BUT -- OUR HEARTS ARE WITH
THE STAFF OF CHARLIE HEBDO AND
THEIR FAMILIES TONIGHT.
I KNOW VERY FEW PEOPLE
GO INTO TO COMEDY, YOU KNOW, AS
AN ACT OF COURAGE MAINLY BECAUSE
IT SHOULDN'T HAVE TO BE THAT.
IT SHOULDN'T BE AN ACT OF
COURAGE. IT SHOULD BE TAKEN AS
ESTABLISHED LAW.
BUT THOSE GUYS AT HEBDO HAD IT,
AND THEY WERE KILLED FOR THEIR
CARTOONS.
STARK REMINDER THAT FOR THE MOST
PART THE LEGISLATORS AND
JOURNALISTS AND INSTITUTIONS
THAT WE JAB AND RIDICULE
ARE NOT IN ANY WAY THE
ENEMY.
FOR HOWEVER FRUSTRATING OR
OUTRAGED THE BACK AND FORTH CAN
BECOME IT'S STILL A BACK AND
FORTH A CONVERSATION AMONGST
THOSE ON LET'S CALL IT
TEAM CIVILIZATION.
AND THIS TYPE OF VIOLENCE ONLY
CLARIFIES THAT REALITY.
BUT OF COURSE, OF COURSE OUR
GOAL TONIGHT IS NOT TO MAKE
SENSE OF THIS BECAUSE THERE IS
NO SENSE TO BE MADE OF THIS.
OUR GOAL AS IT IS ALWAYS IS TO
KEEP GOING. KEEP CALM AND CARRY
ON OR WHATEVER VERSION OF THAT
SAYING IS IN YOUR DORM ROOM.